en realidad existen varias políticas en
varios países que sí son vinculantes
pero a nivel global todavía no tenemos
ninguna política vinculante que
realmente se se va a hacer cargo de este
problema de la contaminación por
plástico pero si vemos más a nivel
nacional Sí hemos visto varios países
prohibiendo por ejemplo las voces
plásticas o otros tipos de plástico de
un solo uso hemos visto países que ya
trabajan en proyectos de ley que son se
llama
responsabilidad extendida del productor
o leyes rep pero no tenemos nada
unificado entonces claramente eso ese es
un tema que es muy complejo porque
claramente el problema de la
contaminación o plástico es un problema
global
claro y este esta problemática llega por
el uso masivo del plástico se están
dando también a nivel global algún tipo
de incentivos están buscando políticas
para la reducción de ese consumo sí
correcto y por eso también Viajé la
semana pasada a París Francia para
negociar justamente ese tratado global
del plástico que se está llevando ya más
o menos un año y va a durar hasta el
próximo año Porque necesitamos
justamente incentivar la reducción del
primero que nada la reducción de la de
la producción de plástico aquí no
hablamos solamente la la contaminación
pero necesitamos
reducir la la producción de plástico
luego podemos también substituir cierto
plásticos por otros materiales pero
tampoco es suficiente entonces
necesitamos Buscar un cambio sistémico
completo que incluye todo este distintos
estrategias para para terminar con la
contaminación por plástico y y algo que
ha sido muy común entre los consumidores
es limpiar playas reciclar más si tienes
impacto pero es por lejos no suficiente
para terminar con ese problema y por eso
también necesitamos un esfuerzo global
de todos los países también de los
consumidores de las mismas empresas para
cambiar el sistema porque ese sistema
hemos creado también entre todos y
precisamente de ese compromiso global
Quiero preguntarle debería haber mayor
compromiso de los países desarrollados
para compensar su contribución al
problema o en este caso urgen medidas
igualitarias para todos
obviamente se está buscando un poco una
combinación por un lado para hacerse
cargo de toda la contaminación que ya
existe Pero por otro lado tenemos que
mirar hacia el futuro y Buscar
mecanismos de Cómo reducir justamente la
contaminación en el en el futuro y
claramente ahí los países que son
productores de plásticos pero más
antes de eso también los países que
justamente
los países petroquímicos digamos también
tiene un rol muy importante porque al
final se dice que ellos ya se ven
afectados obviamente por el tratado de
París el cambio climático entonces están
buscando quizás un negocio atractivo que
también es justamente plástico que viene
de fuentes fósiles entonces por ahí
también se está buscando una mayor
responsabilidad de países que son parte
del inicio del sistema que se llama más
soluciones aguas arribas cuando
obviamente la basura se genera al final
entonces claramente Ahí es donde tenemos
Buscar soluciones al inicio y al final
de la vida útil del plástico